I grew up Jewish I grew up in a Jewish
household um born and raised when you're
young you just think oh Zionist most
most Jews who are around you are
zionists especially in America that's
just the fact and our our counselors
were Israeli soldiers from the IDF yeah
there is and was I remember when I was
there an anti- Palestinian sentiment and
anti-muslim sentiment yeah get the out
of the country this is Jewish country
only you
Muslims there is no permission from the
toah to have any Mercy before the ships
came two former American vessels
carrying nearly 4,000 Jewish refugees
arrive at the Port of hia Palestine and
the Muslims and Jews were there living
in peace and and we went from Italy to
Palestine it was not Israel yet it was
Palestine in France when the Nazis were
coming to take the Jews Muslims were
forging documents was just a prophet in
right signifant no no no we don't even
believe he was a prophet what do you
think he was so we're here with Jacob
yakub who comes from a Eskenazi Jewish
background you grew up in a Jewish
household you went to Hebrew schools
studying with Orthodox rabbis you even
went to a a youth camp but it was uh you
distinguish it was actually a Zionist
Youth Camp that's right and we'll talk a
little bit about your background some
history we'll try to dispel some of the
myths people right now with everything
that's going on in Phil Gaza they're
trying to make this Muslim Jewish things
like Muslims want to eradicate all Jews
you being someone who comes from this
background you can help us to have a
good nice context understanding of this
inshallah God willing
[Music]
in I love
you when I was ready to talk about it I
would I was explaining how much respect
I have for the faith of Islam
welcome to the show the
show how are you alhamdulillah so let's
start okay tell me you're in a nutshell
just for the people didn't see the
program that we done your story tell us
a little bit about your background so
you know I I grew up Jewish I grew up in
a Jewish household um born and raised
here in Florida and not too far from the
dean Center maybe an hour away
and I grew up you know mostly secular
you know in but I but I didn't have no
connection to my religion I was
constantly involved with learning Hebrew
learning about Judaism um you know
learning the Torah and and learning all
the traditions and customs and I I went
you know from first grade onward I I
went to uh you know an orthodox an ultra
Orthodox they call the kabad here um
Hebrew school and I learned Hebrew from
them and I you know I went to a lot of
events there and you know later on I I
started going to a reformed synagogue so
going from I guess the top of the
religious totem P to the bottom is where
it was mostly secular um still going you
know Friday night services and learning
all the prayers and I had my bar
mitzvah and you know I but as I was
growing older I didn't have as strong a
connection U because I felt that there
were just some things in Judaism that
they weren't explaining to me about how
how life was and how was supposed to
work it always felt like they just kept
going against what they were teaching um
but as growing up I did also go to this
this Jewish um this Jewish summer camp
and it was in North Carolina and they
you know it wasn't really a surprise
that they were a Zionist organization
you know when you're young you just
think oh Zionist most most Jews who are
around you are Zionist especially in
America that's just the fact most of
them are very pro- Israel and they think
it's their Homeland and so on and so
forth and we grew up like that's just
second nature so you know going to this
Camp it was you know Jewish you know
they still kept uh they kept the Sabbath
they made sure you know no electronics
no you know nothing nothing's happening
during Sabbath is a day of rest you're
not learning you're not working you're
just enjoying every morning you go and
you pray and you have the same prayer
service and then on Friday night and
Saturday morning that's the Sabbath you
go to you go to pray and it's it's very
it's very you know involved um but
during the day what you're learning
aside from just you know having the same
activities as any other summer camp you
know swimming Sports uh rock climbing
going in the lake you know um you're
constantly being
fed uh
Israeli uh you know everything about
Israel it's you learn
Hebrew same thing you're learning more
conversational like here words here and
there to use um but they they teach you
about Israel they teach you about the
geography of Israel the history of
Israel they even during color like they
have color Wars is a very popular thing
during those summer camps where you know
there are like four teams or so on and
they they all fight against each other
with sports and activities but they
always have a um one event or theme that
they go around and I remember one of the
years the theme were were um Israeli
Heroes and they're all War soldiers who
fought in you know most of these batt
against Muslims and they treat them like
they killed terrorists their the entire
time and they they teach about so you
know they kept they kept and our our
counselors were Israeli soldiers from
the IDF yeah actively in of course
everyone in Israel has to go to the IDF
men or woman you know think it's men
three years women for two years
something about that um I don't know if
it's changed I haven't looked into that
much but I know for sure two years for
men is it two now two years for women
one year for women something yeah all I
know is they have to be at least a
certain amount of time to serve exactly
um just to get training and and they're
all act they're all um you know active
duty soldiers if they're called in um
then they have to fight but a lot of the
ones who came and were counselors were
they were in it for the long term they
actually came they were boot camp
training commanders they were
snipers and at this camp that you were
part of my in my cabin I I had uh I
remember one of the years uh one of one
of my uh counselors in the cabin was a
sniper and you know for bedtime stories
he tell about how he um went on went on
missions to assassinate the terrorists I
mean I'm not making this up yeah whether
he was or not is another question I
would hope I hope he was but because
maybe he was just trying to get us all
thrilled but the same thing goes they
were they were kind of spoon feeding us
what we should think about Israel and
you know I went to Israel in 2012 I went
to you visited Israel I've been U right
before my bar mitzvah and so I saw with
my own eyes you know so you were Bar
Mitzvah also that's right what does that
mean for someone who just doesn't know
what does that mean to be Bar Mitzvah
like a coming of age uh you're you've
become an adult so you know in Judaism
that's you're of age to be able to you
know read the Torah you're actually able
to study it now and so Bar Mitzvah is
basically you're leading that Saturday
morning service on the Sabbath and you
uh you're the one reading the Torah
portion yourself you're reading the ha
you're you're giving the theba the
sermon about the Torah portion and um
that that signifies it's it's the same
with women actually they do the same
thing more so in um uh I would say the
the Le the Lesser conservative or you
know reform and conservative and some
Orthodox as well do it to the same
extent they call it B Mitzvah um and so
they'll do the same thing they'll get up
on the on you mimar you know do the same
thing um 13 years old for men and 12y
old 12 years old for women um and yeah I
mean usually for most kids it's actually
just a time to celebrate and have fun
it's it's just like a wedding you you'll
invite all your friends and have fancy
food and party really it's a party um
that's what it is like for I mean I've
seen kids spend more money on their Bar
Mitzvah than on their wedding wow or
parents rather MH so that signifies
something and I remember in isra I was
studying my Torah portion I was
memorizing it it was Deuteronomy um I
think 22 or 23 um and you know while I
was there one interesting thing um I
remember being in the Golan Heights
which is um the contested area where uh
bordering Syria and we went on a like a
Jeep tour through it and I remember
there we saw barbed wire fencing and um
and we see a sign that says danger
landmines so behind there there were
plenty of Mines it was a Minefield and
he says you see our tour guy you see in
English and in Hebrew it says Minefield
but in in Arabic it says picnic area wow
so and it's not the only time that we
kept hearing like you know oh don't
trust the Palestinian taxis they're
going to rip you off you know there is
and was I remember when I was there an
anti- Palestinian sentiment and
anti-muslim sentiment here get the out
of the country this is Jewish country
only we don't need Muslims here
and you know they were doing it in just
but they didn't they weren't really
laughing you know they they do it to so
the just so this there was a
Minefield and it was displayed Minefield
on the Israeli side but then on the in
Arabic so in Hebrew he was joking he was
he was joking that in Arabic it doesn't
actually say picnic area okay but
because if he's speaking to Americans
yes you can fool them but the thing is
they they really do think that way way
oh I see what you're saying right they
they really think that they're they're
just they're just there they're just
extra they're just there like they don't
mind playing around with the idea of oh
he just threw that out threw that out
there yeah okay I see what you're saying
it was it was it was a joke but it was
but he but they they hold the sentiment
yeah so how was your time at that camp
and then just in general what was the
education you were getting with what was
going on with your the neighboring state
the neighboring Christians Palestinians
Muslim Palestinians there how were you
made to view
them it really was you know Israelis are
your are your friends Israelis are the
ones who will take care of you the
Palestinians are not going to take care
of you take advantage of you um you know
we learned about the war in I remember
while we were at Camp they had a um a
ticket like like a daily counter of um
gilad the the IDF Soldier who was
um taken hostage um and they were they
had a countdown or you know every for
every single day they they' move the
counter of how many days he was captured
for so very anti-g Gaza anti-muslim
anti- Palestinian rhetoric U that was
that was given there of course they they
would never go into Islam as as a
religion never they just kind of lump
them together um you know
they most of the time they will just use
the term
Hamas at that time especially it was
because that's when it all kind of
started where you know I was in camp at
what 2008 2009 I think 2009 2010 yes so
that's when you know it was it was at
its peak of you know this is new and
this is a lot worse than what we
imagined at least in their eyes so we
were getting a lot of that rhetoric just
put in front of us and
um it actually inspired me in 2012 or
2013 that year 8th grade I decided to do
we have a National History Day where um
usually social study students who are in
like honors class or something they will
do a project that takes up a good
portion of the grade and they take the
day off and present it to uh people to
judge and it's just you show a
historical project and you
know that has to determine some part of
history and I chose mine to be the
Israeli Palestinian conflict you know um
my award was the most thought-provoking
mhm because why they can't really choose
a side but what did I end up discovering
while I was looking into I knew when I
was 13 years old that it's not Israel is
the good guy and Palestine is the bad
guy at 13 I was already like okay we
have something going on here that is way
deeper it's it's it's en roted in
something way more chaotic and um you
know just like um you know Dan Cohen you
had him on um not too long ago the other
Jewish also independent journalist
exactly um he he's the um filmmaker of
killing Gaza that's right yes and
talking about the history of Zionism you
know and so you were already at that age
thinking like there's more to this yeah
and I I of course I put it on the back
burner ironically I left early from uh
National History Day to go to a Jewish
um youth youth event uh on the other
side of Florida but same thing same
thing applies it was just um at that
point it was I had it in the back of my
mind that it's not just left and it's
not it's not white black and white and
there's a lot more to it you know um a
lot more history that that makes it um
not what you think tell me this so when
you hear this statement that's put out
there that Muslims want to wipe out Jews
or this is a Jewish Muslim thing what
goes to your mind being someone who
comes from a Jewish background well I
can tell you I had a lot of uh
discussion with my family regarding this
of course my mom still Jewish you know
and she grew up she was part of hadasa
the the women's Zionist organization and
um you know my family is all pro-israel
and they contined to be so that's just
how they grew up that's they learned and
but I've had discussions with my mom and
I've brought to light a lot of this
history that makes it more clear that
it's you know when something goes
against morality it should be shown from
no matter who is at fault you need to
see that it goes against morality which
of course it goes against Islam whatever
goes against morality goes against Islam
so I'm bringing forward this is what our
religion teaches do not kill women do
not kill children do not kill innocent
people and you know there's no but and
so you know that's of course I have to
condemn any any form of that no matter
what side that comes from and no matter
what there is never a case where
Collective punishment is
allowed it's not like it's not something
that they're asking for the the the
Goins never agreed that you know
whatever Hamas does will accept the no
they they know that they're they're in
this situation where they're just trying
to live their life they're barely living
in poverty it's lower than poverty they
they they can't survive without the help
of the UN I mean it's it's such a
terrible situation and you know may God
give them a way out I mean so it's just
it's not something that um you know if
you look at history and the way that uh
Jews were treated in in you know in the
historical past with with Islam it was
never like this it was never oh you know
um we're going to uh you you do you do a
little thing to us so we're gonna we're
going to completely wipe you out that's
not how it was it's you know it's
supposed to be very balanced and I'd
love to talk more about that yeah let me
get you uh you your reaction so this is
really important so differentiating I
mean what you it's very clear in
Islam uh how would you categorize in
your experience now let's say rabbis
like this who are coming out and they're
quoting
the Old
Testament
and they're talking about pretty much no
mercy and it's is including children
right innocent women non-combatants
there is no permission from the tah to
have any Mercy
whatsoever during
war not on children not on women not on
anybody how would you classify this
Rabbi with the rabbis that you learn
from we don't want to want to play that
game like oh got you here look you know
and if there's something that's out of
context like they do with with the Quran
they'll take one verse they'll throw it
out there say look Islam is violent but
you just have to read the verse before
and after it look at things in context
it's very clear non-combatants not to be
touched Rules of Engagement everything
is just laid out because we truly
believe like Allah says that Prophet
Muhammad was sent in of Mercy to Mankind
and we'll get into some of those
examples of Mercy where he was actually
fighting
anti-Semitism um and this wasn't even
something at that time cuz they're
semites also right so it's crazy but
they were they were fighting this uh
this hate towards any kind of people
right so now how would you classify this
Rabbi who's pretty much saying No Mercy
to anybody are we are we just not
understanding him correctly or how would
you classify this type because this this
could be very scary and we see what's
happening now in Gaza I mean there's
like no mercy towards any of the kids
that are just being annihilated right
um I mean I know what he was going to
say after that if you understand the
point of this war he's going to say well
it's to fight idolatry it's going to
fight it's about fighting polytheism and
you know we as Muslims we also are our
whole point is to you know is to strive
to make monotheism the main message that
everyone can learn about and can can
believe in and should believe in but
what he the way that he's saying it no
mercy towards women and children that's
not even in the dud that's not in the
Torah they both explain
the same way as the Quran that they're
to be secure they're to be safe and you
know they're there are a lot of people
who will reinterpret the Torah that's
the what I learned that's what got me
out of Judaism in the first place is
constant reinterpretation of the Torah I
mean you'll find rabbis all over the
spectrum of what they believe about
Israel about Zionism about Judaism about
how to interpret texts how um what what
should be followed as far as um how do
you uh on Passover are you allowed to
eat rice and beans are or or has can
only be such something so separate like
you know little things here and there
but some of those things are not little
at all but you have these verses in
Deuteronomy you have them where it's
talking about when you go into a town
just pretty much women children
annihilate everything have you've seen
some of these right A lot of them are
misinterpreted misinterpreted I think so
yeah yeah so but now he's he's pretty
much going and saying giving a green
light yeah well that's the I think the
way I would classify it is there are
three types yeah what you were saying
before there was three types of yeah the
ones that follow you know the ones that
are open to Dara the ones that are open
to listening that's you know you have
people like like abdah Salam who we
talked about um you know last time um
you know the one of the first major
rabbis who accepted Islam you know you
have S you have other how was the chief
Rabbi you just mentioned
that during the time of prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him he saw that this was
he fit all the descriptions of prophet
coming and he accepted him yeah exactly
yes um and he understood he understood
the real message of the Torah and he
didn't listen that's because he
understood the real okay he he memorized
the Torah yeah he was one of the people
who actually he knew most of it if not
all of it by heart and um and there's a
story I'll I'll mention in a bit um
perhaps but uh um because it goes in
line with with how
the prophet Muhammad upon him uh treated
the Torah and treated the Jewish people
um but you know so people like him who
uh they heard the message and they they
they saw they saw the stuff that um you
know the Jews at their time were saying
this is what we believe this is how we
interpret the text he says no these
interpretations don't make sense they
don't fit in line with with what how I
understood from from what was very clear
in the Torah and and other parts of the
of the oral tradition um parts of to the
tomwood because the tomwood is in two
parts you know the the real oral uh law
and then the interpretation of that and
then the rabbis who who are interpreting
that are from the same time as Jesus
peace be upon him we don't really know
to what extent I mean I've read part t
with myself and I have to say some of
their interpretations are wacky at the
least wacky
regarding a number of things the you
know what's allowed when it's allowed to
lie when in court for instance again
like versus like a Jew versus a non-jew
in court uh the a Jew can circum can
circumvent the Jud the judge can
circumvent the
non-jew uh in favor of the Jewish person
just because he's Jewish he can try to
slightly squeeze around the law to make
it so that the non-jew gets convicted
rather than the Jewish person wow I mean
that just shows you there I mean so this
is in there people go check this out
that's in the talmud that's in the
talmud yeah I that reminds me of the
story of um one of the
calebs from the time of prophet Muhammad
peace and blessing who came after
Ali and you know the story when he was
the caleff and now there was issue with
him and the the Jew and they went to the
court do you know about this story
remind me so they went to the court and
then like he's the head of state now so
as the head of state you would think now
hold on the judge the who's there he's
going to rule in favor of the head of
state he's there like
but then he actually ruled in favor of
the Jew right you know about the story
I've heard it yeah yeah and then um the
if I recollect correctly the judge he
asked him seems like you're upset about
something to Ali the head of state he
says yeah because you you you because he
addressed him by by his uh his K or his
nickname or something almost seeing like
that like favored him a little bit he
didn't want that he wanted Justice
real Justice all across we have so many
examples of this exactly so that
reminded me when you talking about
there's no slant towards you know
because you're Muslim it's Justice all
across the board exactly MH that's it
there's there's Justice it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter um and you know
you can see that all across the
prophet's life I mean so the other two
groups the ones who um this middle one's
quite interesting the ones who stick
with the Torah but still don't believe
in the message of right they but they're
but they they don't lie and they don't
they're not deceitful and they don't try
to circumvent or anything they're a rare
group to find but you'll find one like
in the time of the Prophet P upon him
there was one by the name of
um uh and he was one of the leaders of
the
the um one of the tribes one of the
Jewish tribes there and in
Medina and so you know one thing that we
know is that the prophet P when he moved
to Medina when he migrated to Medina to
escape the persecution of the meccans M
he EST you know they they made him the
leader but he established the
constitution of Medina which it was a
defensive pact between every single
tribe who was there we defend you if
you're attacked you defend us if we're
attacked and we do not attack each other
ever as long as we're in this pact and
and you don't go against The Pact MH
then this is this is this is you know
cre the creation of a state really you
know it's it's um they're creating a
society uh and so you know
there in in this when uh the Battle of
was taking place mhm um the most of the
it was happening on the day of the
Sabbath on Saturday for the Jews right
yes and so there's a statement in
Judaism where you're not supposed to
voluntarily go to war unless it's fully
in defense of your own group most of the
Jews of said no not fighting because
it's the Sabbath so they're going
against The Pact in favor of um a
preference a preference that we we
prefer not to fight M but
um one of their leaders said you don't
understand the deeper meaning of this we
have to fight and it's been it's been
said um Allah we don't know if he really
died as a Muslim some people say that he
does but it's more it's more evident he
probably died still believing in Judaism
but he still believed perhaps the
prophet was even um Messianic in
character uh so they he believed in his
prophethood to a in a way and his and
and then but in a different way than
other Jews did but still had a deep
meaning that he believed and due to what
I read actually some very clear uh
interpretations at least you could see
from the text um from the texts of of uh
um the like the later prophets mhm
anyway he ended up dying in the Battle
of he was the first Jewish martyr of
Islam and he left an entire field of
date palms an entire Garden of date
palms um which he actually put in the
name of Muhammad Sall alaihi wasallam so
that ended up being the very first W the
first Islamic trust in all of Islam in
Islamic history so you know and Prophet
Muhammad said of him he was the best of
Jews
he honored him even if he didn't die
upon Islam again we don't really know
but from the way it was said he was the
best of Jews not the best of Muslims who
became you know it's pretty it would
seem that he just died as a as a you
know in upon his religion but still
honored him for that mhm um so because
he honored the treaty and he was he was
there for them and none of the other
Jews ever fought for the prophet Isam
except for maybe a couple a lot of them
ended up taking their shahada later so
that's that middle line right the rare
the rare version of of a middle just
like Abu Talib you know the the uncle of
he never accepted Islam but he defended
the prophet right so those two groups
are super tiny the vast majority are
what you see in the of the Prophet what
you see in throughout you know
throughout history and it talks about
them in the Quran like this it's the
group who distort their own inter and
they interpret their own texts
differently they might add something to
it or remove something from it to suit
their own desires not that the text
necessarily had to be changed for them
to just omit it when verbally you know
they'll they they would try to teach the
um they'll translate parts of the Torah
in Arabic to teach some of the Muslims
what they know and then they' come to
the prophet and say what is the verdict
on that they say he says don't affirm it
nor deny it just say we believe in the
books as they were revealed or something
along those lines yes you know
so so that did that increase you your
Iman your faith the more you study this
the more you looked into this and now
that when you talk to your mother or you
talk to other people in your family
Jewish Family that now are they clear at
this I mean do they know like the
history before before the ships came two
former American vessels carrying nearly
4,000 Jewish refugees arrive at the Port
of hia Palestine jammed like cat on the
rusty craft the fugitives end their
Bleak Voyage which began at a Black Sea
port and we went from Italy to Palestine
it was not Israel yet it was Palestine
yeah what how did you get you went by
boat by boat we went to Israel when
Israel was not Israel yet two and people
were coming to Palestine and the Muslims
and Jews were there living in peace and
Muslims welcomed anytime they were
persecuted Jews were persecuted they
were welcomed by the Muslims Muslims
were actually saving helping to protect
the Jews from anti-Semitism from the
hate that uh they were and the
persecution they were going under right
even during World War II you have
Albania um who amongst all the Muslim
countries they they took a lot of
European Jews and hid them and and kept
them safe um they they think suffered as
far as in Europe the least you see that
that has me just thinking if you know
that that's like part of that's clear I
mean you have um David
Warstein Islam saved the jury JC essay
it's there in Jewish Chronicles I mean
you have so many historians just you
cannot deny this no in France when the
Nazis were coming to take the Jews
Muslims were forging documents for yeah
the Jews to say that they were Muslims
too so how how can how can it's like is
this taught at all at all is this
something that when you were growing up
did you learn about this no you didn't
no and you know only later realizing you
know the king of Morocco when when
Hitler said bring you know send your
Jews to us he says we don't have your
Jews here only Moroccans you know it's
it's kind of a it's a statement right
that look our people are our people if
they're under us they're our they're
they're ours and that's what the prophet
he he always did that he never fought
against Jewish people
ever except that they broke a they broke
a treaty they they committed high
treason it's the only time and even then
he was always uh very very um uh you
know he gave he gave them some leeway in
every case he always gave them leeway so
for instance um you know one of the most
you know talked about story that uh
non-muslims love to bring up uh with us
is is the attack so they say you know
it's the attack on Buu yes that has
always been the
most distorted story I think in the
history of the S of the
Prophet you know this is a defensive
pact that they broke and they weren't
the only ones that broke it all of them
the major groups broke it and banad they
were just exiled for it they were exiled
but um
B the first during the first instance of
rebellion they were given a pass they
said it's okay you guys can stay there
but then they broke it again and they
started fighting again after be how you
know that's not it's not it's not a
onetime offense it's the continue to so
from then from that point the Muslims
had to defend themselves because the
prophet said I fear I fear B he says
like he he says take arms I def I fear
of them we need to defend ourselves and
eventually they laid Siege to the city
because first of all they they were you
know they wanted to make sure the
Muslims were small and they needed to
make sure that they were safe and was
fighting alongside um all the other
Pagan Arabs and they needed to defend
themselves and so it was it was very
clear once they had surrendered they
said we we defer the our case to S one
of the Jewish converts who they trust
mhm and what does s do he says I'll
judge you based on your
text and he takes Deuteronomy 20:
12-4 saying if you know basically if you
lay if the city uh lays SE lay Siege on
you you lay Siege on them and and
continue to fight until they're they're
done until it's surrendered and when you
do kill the combatants the male
combatants and take the women and
children as uh as uh as booty as um
Spoils of War yes and enjoy The Spoils
of War in the name of the Lord your God
this is in the Bible this is Deuteronomy
20: 12-
14 it says it right there it's Bible you
can't if you're a Christian if you're
Jewish you can't say this is this is
this in the Bible you know you can say
oh I I think they're fables like we know
some popular people say that was the
Judgment that they agreed to that was in
their own text they agreed to the
whatever said and that's not and that's
the thing he ruled based on what they
would have done if the tables would have
turned mhm if the tables would have
turned and they and they thought based
on their text they would have done the
same to the Muslims because it's in
their text it's the Torah they believe
in it mhm they really do so that's why
they knew what was coming they did um
and so that's not the only time that
during the time of the Prophet that you
know judgment was I would say justice
was placed back in the hands of the
Torah there was another moment including
ABD Salam where he uh some some people
committed uh uh premarital relations or
outside of U marriage relations yes and
in the Jewish tribe and they asked the
prophet to judge judge between them and
so they actually came to him seeking
judgment isn't that interesting they
came to the they came to the prophet now
maybe they thought that he was going to
be more lenient maybe he said judge how
you please maybe he thought they wanted
to test him as you know to see if he was
a prophet because they kept testing him
in different ways yeah um but he
said what uh you know what do you do
what what what do you rule and they say
well we we cover their faces with coal
and we we lash we lash them right and he
says well what about the verses of aim
of stoning because he knew about the he
knew he knew you've heard about it and
they say there's nothing in the Torah
that says that they said that there's
nothing in the Torah that says
thatd Salam was there and he says you
are liars bring forth the Torah and
there's a very interesting Hadith that
isn't in the main ones but it's it's
it's Hass it's still good and it's it's
an addition to it when they brought out
the Torah they actually went to the Fort
the Jewish Fortress the Propet and ABD
they went to the the Jewish Fortress
where they they brought up the
Torah uh and the prophet was sitting on
a cushion and when they brought up the
Torah they were about to put it down on
the ground it seemed he took out the
cushion under
his you know under from underneath him
he sat on the ground and then plac the
Torah on the cushion honoring because he
knew that the Revelation from Allah was
in this this was a revelation this what
we had left of it say yeah exactly he
honored he knew that the Revelation was
in there and he never wanted to he
always treated it with utter respect and
then one of the Jewish uh priests that
from from that area came started reading
but placed his hand over the uh the part
that talks about stoning and he read
from what was before it and after it but
ABD Salam he had already memorized the
Torah so when he heard that he says this
is not correct he lifted the hand from
the guy who was reading it and he asked
the other Jewish people to read what he
was covering up and it was that was a
scholar of Judaism who accepted Islam
ABD yes yes yes so he called him out on
that he called him out on that right W
and
so that so then the prophet says that's
your ruling I rule based upon your book
mhm and they so you know that's that's
the end of the story MH it's they kept
it's because they kept twisting and
altering their religion the prophet he
he never he never cursed them for
anything except for things that they did
which went against what Allah has
decreed for them so now you can see with
all these games how the text how was
changed in the past so what they had was
altered because they're manipulating the
text Allah calls them out woe to those
who write the book with their hands and
woe to them for what they gain by that
right Allah is saying see that's why the
Quran was sent exactly the last and
final Testament authentic preserved and
we have an its original and those who uh
saw the Fulfillment of the prophecy
that's in their mention of the coming of
prophet Muhammad is that right right
it's true and Prophet Muhammad whenever
he heard uh if he revealed some if Allah
revealed something in the Quran and then
the prophet he would he would not deny
if a Jewish person wanted to come in and
and seek his counsel they would come in
and they'll say uh you know uh they'll
say I have heard do you wish to know
about this uh and this is what we've
heard about the day of judgment this is
what we've heard about this and they'll
share the stories of what they know and
they line right up with the Quran they
they they affirm the Quran and whenever
he whenever the prophet would hear that
what would he do he would start smiling
and laughing MH because he loves hearing
the affirmation that this like he gets a
Revelations you know uh peace be upon
him and and he gets affirmation from
what is what is previously revealed that
clearly was was previously revealed he
he he doesn't dislike being in uh you
know in this vicinity and so it's only
in the cases when they were fighting
against
him that's when he had to draw lines but
he never uh oppressed them even even
when during like the Battle of K for
instance um and uh that's where um bad
and you know they they uh because they
broke their treaty the same way
um they you know they went and they
fought but then even after the fighting
they let them stay on the
land and they just shared in the
crops they they always because they
asked can we stay here they said sure
they they asked got leniency they didn't
say um please let us be and they say no
you you're you all need to die mhm
that's not that's not the first time
that happened that consistent leniency
whenever any type of intercession
whether from them or from someone else
they say please have mercy on them there
was always mercy so this is something
this is uh totally false it's a lie it's
something that's perpetuated by people
who have just no historical context no
historical references to this that and
it's clear clear as day for anyone who
looks into this that and it's and that
um Muslims because Muslims historically
do not have a history of persecuting
Jews they don't actually actually and
this is not to um step on any toes from
our Christian and friends and neighbors
but it's actually the Christians were
persecuting the Jews definitely you want
to go down there Muslims don't have and
I'm this is just historically this is
the um facts right uh and we're not
trying to hurt nobody's feelings but
it's a Str relationship now that a
certain group of people who were
protected and they ran to from
persecution from the Christians now I
don't know maybe some of the Christian
zionists have this guilt now and now
they're actually supporting this injust
the injustices that are happening
happening against innocent human beings
so the whole love love love is out the
window and I don't know if you know much
about the prophecy that they're pushing
to try to to be fulfilled from both so
you have a Jewish prophecy trying to
fulfilled uh and can you you know
anything about this and then the
Christian can you can you elaborate on
this I think the majority of it come
from the seventh day Adventists M um
where they believe that you know once a
lot of the a lot of these groups you
know um and they're not the only ones
there are other religious groups as well
that believe that it all comes down to
the coming of the Messiah mhm and
whatever happens then it's like once the
mesiah comes once once Jesus peace be
upon him we believe he will come down
and fight the Antichrist at right um now
whoever is a partisan with the
Messiah they're the ones who are going
to wipe out the you know the
evildoers
so for the Christians they believe it's
a the sday Adventists you know once he
comes and all the Jews will be killed
because they and all the all the Muslims
will be like you know because they're
because they realize they were wrong mhm
and that and they're going they're not
even going to see that it's Jesus and so
on and so forth you know I might be a
bit wrong about this but it's it's still
a general principle and the Jews have
the same uh understanding of the Messiah
it's not necessarily the death to the
same extent well except that
Prophet um in before before his coming
the reason why they were in Arabia in
the first place was because they knew
that the last messenger was coming
that's an important Point why were the
Jews around this area because they were
expecting a messenger to come the final
messenger and they would keep telling
the and the people of or medina before
it was Medina they would tell them once
our Prophet comes we will we will fight
against you and kill all of you they
would say that multiple times
consistently so then why didn't they
when they saw all the signs they knew
that he was like Allah said they know
him like they know their own fathers
well I'd love to bring forth The Story
of safia B the mother of the Believers
may Allah be pleased with her um you
know the wife of the Prophet BC upon him
who was safia well the her father H was
one of the chiefs
of one of the other you know uh tribes
in in that you know in that area at that
time and while she was very young she
always her uh you know her uncle and and
her father they were very playful
towards her they give her a lot of love
but there was one day when they heard
about the prophet when he was when he
was they heard about he was the chief
Jewish leader of that tribe yes okay so
she overheard them um after one day they
realized that she wasn't getting any
attention so she decided to listen in on
them and they they were speaking to the
uncle asks the father is that him and
he'll say yes that's after they went to
go see him to investigate even further
right mhm
is that him they said yes verily it's
him there's no doubt that it's him even
they confirm this is coming from her
testimony right yes yes
and and then he asked are we going to
follow him and she said and and the
father said no verily he'll be our enemy
until the end of time now the question
is why is it because it wasn't one of
their own that's part of it because they
believed that uh partially because they
believe any any of the people of ish of
of the you know is am if they came from
his descendants they believed them to be
know cursed in a way or at least they
they believed uh because he came from
ishma yeah because they they don't
believe they didn't believe beet that's
that racism now that we're better than
you so is that the that's the main
reason it's not better per se it's that
they they already had a um uh they
already had some you know somebody in
their uh in in you know in the past of
the rabbis basically interpreted things
this way um to say that you know only
Prophet Prophet only came stemming from
is uhhuh and wouldn't and wouldn't come
from another Direction theyve already
ruled but they're confirming this is him
they've confirmed case but it's based on
not just that but also if he comes what
happens to their wealth what happens to
their to their society what happens to
the power that they had they had the
same issues with the prophet as the
Pagan uh meccans mhm same issue right
what's going to happen to their wealth
what's going to happen to the they they
had all this power in their society I
mean they were constantly going between
the the but they had there were a lot of
Jewish tribes there they had a lot of
power yes and so they use that and the
distortions of their texts to affirm
their position right but it doesn't take
a lot of uh research to know you know
abam didn't take he didn't hesitate one
bit in fact when he was
asking he
um you know asking the questions right
the famous Hadith of how he became a
Muslim um you know uh what's one of the
the first sign the first portant of the
hour uh what are um what's the first
meal in what is uh how do you determine
the the um uh the the gender of a child
or or the the likeness of the child you
know but right after he said that
Prophet said
uh
well has informed me of these answers
and what was the response jel is the
enemy of the Jews why did he say that
because always came with the bad news in
their times right always came with uh
you know the Commandments of War always
came with bad you know so they
considered him to be a bad Omen CU they
believe in bad Omens and so but the
thing is that didn't deter ABD Salam
because what was the response as well
the prophet then recites from the Quran
saying those who take as an enemy and
continued and from there then he told
the three answers that
were extremely accurate that only a
really properly learned Rabbi would
possibly be able to
know so on the
spot uh took his shahada and said verily
the Jews are liars and if you were to
ask any and if you were to ask them
about me surely they'll invent a lie
about me and and you know that goes back
to that story that I remember talking
about last time at first he was the best
of the best and the second he took his
shahada in front of them he is the worst
of the worst and started creating lies
about him yes when he when he asked them
to ask ask them about me who I am right
so and then they confirm he's the best
of the best and then after he exposed
that no I accepted Islam actually oh
he's the worst of the worst so this goes
to that whole third category right of uh
you know the the worst of the worst um
you know there's the unfortunate aspect
that a lot of you know a lot of Muslims
they may not know anything about Judaism
but because of what's happening and
because of you know Mis
misunderstandings of Hadith like the the
um uh the killing of the Jews um in the
time of AD like they don't know it's
about ad they just think oh you know
we're going to be killing Jews like
that's not how that works and it's not
who who you see now and that's it's it's
a very very vague statement and you
shouldn't just accept whatever you read
as um as like oh you can interpret it
yourself no you have to know the whole
history of why like why why why would
they be fighting well it's easy if the
Jews don't believe
in then who's the first Messianic
character who's going to come it's going
to be a it's going to be the Antichrist
and he will come with everything that
will confirm what they have but
distorted because they've already had it
distorted so of course the Jewish people
are going to follow AEL first it's not
even a question in my mind that actually
was one of the reasons why I was I was
certain that Islam was the truth because
it explained how right and I knew that
that's how that like their
understandings of the Messiah and how
they interpret it it would make sense
they follow it at least from their time
and who knows how deel will will you
know convince them um may Allah protect
us but that's that's just it you know
it's it's not it's not that you should
consider everyone to be your enemy in
fact and this is what we're talking
about you know anti-jewish sentiment
even in the time of the Prophet when
when uh
safia uh was was married to the prophet
Isam right once she became married
because at first uh you know she was uh
kind of a um she was seeking Refuge with
in Kar but then after the battle of kar
she was just there and the thing is that
she knew she believed in the proph them
so while she was taken uh you know
really as a as a ref a refugee you could
say or or or captive but the second that
she sees the prophet she takes her
shahada and the prophet was was he was
shocked he says why and that's when you
get the story and they were married
immediately and while they were married
they were walk they were on their camel
right and the camel falls
down and the prophet is Sheltering
safia but the women around say may Allah
may Allah do away or or or um uh do
something with this
Jewish at the time and this is in theith
this is the women had anti-jewish
sentiment even to the wife this freshly
married Fresh Off The Block freshly
married to the prophet MH PE be upon him
and that's how they treat her there were
there was even animosity between the
wives at at some you know some times and
and the thing is sopia had to had to
maintain her honor and um so that's
unfortunately it has nothing to do with
Islam it just has to do with
preconceived notions when there when you
know if there's this large group but
it's not the only people like you just
have a large group who that makes up
what you know the Quran is always
talking about the majority of a of a
people not all of them because it says
and the believing Jews the believing
Christians right and it talks about the
the um like the mercy of Allah being
upon those who truly understand and
they're separate right it's not it's not
about but it's talking about people who
corrupt and they they do wrong and
that's what we're seeing now as well you
know so it has nothing to do with uh
Muslims versus Jews I think we could put
that to rest and any person I mean if
their their heart and mind's open they
can see if they're if they they're
looking at history if they're looking at
um the
text stories that you're sharing with us
I mean it's just pretty much very clear
that uh this is not something that is a
Jewish Muslim thing Muslims do not have
a history of persecuting Jews and
Muslims don't hate Jews Muslims hate
Injustice right Muslims want to live
together in peace with Christians
Muslims and whoever else is there out
there um as long as they're not tring
you or stealing your home stealing your
land obviously uh that's the issue here
right and yeah it doesn't mean that
there's never Injustice from any group
when you have a group of unrighteous
people whether they be Jewish Christian
Muslim if they're if they're if they're
not going by morality the that which God
has sent us right that which Allah has
sent and revealed to us if they're not
going by that then I reject that and and
everyone everyone as a Muslim should
reject that and so those people who look
into history they say oh look the
Muslims look they oppressed this Jewish
these this Jewish group oh they did this
and I say look at the leader mhm do we
do we align oursel with that leader mhm
you say they're Muslim but look more
into it and you can go deeper you can
you have um the most honored woman in
Islam is a Jewish woman Jew woman uh
Mary medium whole chapter named after
her in the Quran Jesus's Blessed Mother
why would uh Prophet Muhammad go ahead
and honor this Jewish uh Jewish woman
Muslim woman who accept because Muslim
is one who submits to the will of God
Jewish is just the the nationality right
how would you define someone can be a
Jew that's their nationality or
ethnicity ethnicity yeah right exactly
so she was of that ethnicity but she was
one who submitted her will to God to
Allah she was a Muslim and she's honored
in Islam Jesus also peace be upon him
and you mentioned him a few times I want
to get get your reaction to
this from from a Jewish point of view
where we don't believe in the Divinity
of Christ I think that there you can
make an argument that the the gospels
which were written he was just a prophet
in signific no no no we don't even
believe he was a prophet what do you
think he was what do you guys think I
mean I what I what do I think he was
historically I think he was a Jew who
tried to lead a revolt against the
Romans and got killed for his trouble
just like a lot of other Jews at that
time who were crucified for trying to
lead revolts against the Roman and got
killed for their trouble Jesus we'll
conclude with this we'll talk about this
for a few minutes this is a person who's
on the front line
he's out there I don't know if you know
about this individual Ben Shapiro
Shapiro and he's stirring up a lot of
hate he's sing he's he's not trying to
um deescalate things he's uh been known
to call a certain group of uh people
Muslims the Palestinians pretty much
animals and he's uh you know kind of
stuff that he's saying so now when you
come here towards Jesus peace be upon
him what do you think in contrast with
now you becoming Muslim accepting Islam
what we believe about Jesus right uh I
know one of your previous guests uh had
spoken about how there are a lot of
different opinions
on um and you know it's there there are
different interpretations of how he
should be whether he's just a you know
just a a rabbi who taught um but maybe
didn't go in line with uh you know the
because he's he's what's his belief if
you ask him as a Christian someone who
follows him and you love Jes Jus you ask
us say we love him right you can't be a
Muslim unless you believe in Jesus you
go to the Hellfire disrespecting him but
he's pretty much in a nice way is it not
a consensus there that pretty much he's
not coming out with it but they believe
that he's like in the lower depths of
Hell
Jesus well most Jews don't even really
believe in Hellfire oh they most don't
so what do they what what's the belief
that Ben Shapiro would have about
Jesus to be hon honest Ben Shapiro he
follows the same uh line of rhetoric as
every other Ultra nationalist Zionist
he's not following to me he doesn't
follow pure Judaism because he doesn't
follow the rabinal he he was on ala he
was up there he was he was one of those
people who first went up there and uh
before you know what what even happened
um a few weeks ago uh I know there was a
very popular he was there right yeah and
stirring up trouble yeah that so you
know just because someone calls himself
Jewish doesn't mean that they are the
resounding voice like what what uh which
which uh rabinal school did he go to
which Yeshiva did he did he study in to
to get his no he's just of course I am
no scholar either I'm just repeating you
know Hadith and things like that I I am
in no way learned and I shouldn't even
begin to say that I'm probably made a
lot of mistakes today but he never
admits to his mistakes that's the
problem yeah and people take him as a as
a Jewish like almost scholar Authority
but he has no Authority and he doesn't
understand his own religion he's just
he's doing the same thing that the
right-wing Ultra nationalist government
is doing which is reinterpreting the
Torah they're going against the ultra
Orthodox Community there they're
oppressing the ultra Orthodox community
in Israel you think he's using this for
his own benefit now I think he believes
what he's saying because he's he's in
line with you know that group yeah um
but it doesn't mean that he are they
equivalent to like the KKK of
Christianity and the Isis D that people
how would you equ how would you equate
them what they they follow a similar IDE
ideological pattern but that it doesn't
mean that they're fully extremist there
are fully extremist Jews out there the
ones who are the settlers that are
gunning down innocent Palestinians in
the West Bank in their illegal set
settlements you know that's different
um than uh you know the ones who uh they
just agree but they don't necessarily
you know so they're they're getting
close to extremism but they haven't
crossed the the main border uh as far as
individuals go you know a collective as
you know the Israeli government and the
IDF and what they're doing against the
gazin like that those are war crimes
it's not even a question yeah they're
war crimes and it's you know it's
unquestionable how bad it is and and how
you know
God God doesn't put Mercy in their
efforts and they're only going to
they're only going to suffer for what
they're doing in the future you know so
do you think if uh
Jews knew what we believe about Jesus
because they're waiting for a messiah to
come right say this is the Messiah he
came you you missed it he's he came
already but now like when I'll speak it
to my last guest Stan uh Stanford um
pass he he believes that if you know the
sincere those who are really looking for
for for the truth because now they have
a twisted understanding about Jesus
because certain people have elevated him
to a god literal Son of God and all you
know all these other made him Divine and
that goes against the first commandment
right right but if they really look into
Islam and they see like hold on this
fits the description of the Messiah that
like you obviously you accepted him then
right I think part of it is I read the
Bible before I read the Quran and I
didn't find anything in the New
Testament that row uh Jesus spe upon him
to that level and you know I don't agree
with Paul I don't consider him an
apostle he I don't believe he saw Jesus
the real Jesus in Damascus I think he
saw the Shayan in Damascus because he
only saw a bright white light but if you
really see a prophet we know and our uh
you know because of the Hadith and and
how if you the prophet says if you see
me in a dream surely you have seen me
but that means he has to take the exact
same form yeah every single you know
aspect of his of of how he looks must be
seen if he's a bright white light he's
not who he says he is he had to have
been the shaan so the devil yes so I
just I cut out everything after the four
canonical gospels really I mean as far
as the Paul Pauline Epistles go if you
just read and of course there's no uh
you could say chant of narration of who
said What in in the they say it's
divinely revealed I say how can that be
when they're just people who who who
heard this this and that and it wasn't
even in Aramaic it was in Greek
regardless of all that you know all due
respect to the religion of Christianity
but I saw flaws as I was reading the
Bible and I was open-minded I was asking
Christians about how to understand this
metaphysically but Jesus peace be upon
him had said the first commandment the
first he was ask if we're going to if
we're going to um the most important
thing to follow from the book follow
from the Torah or the most important
thing ever to know
he said the two things
are the Sha which is hereo Israel the
Lord is your god the Lord is one and
then the second thing is love your
neighbor as
yourself and if that's it and the first
thing was pure monotheism why would and
and there's there's no proof of any
Trinity there's no proof of of there's
no establishment of pure Divinity
there's what you call the Divine passive
which is voice where you don't know if
he was just speaking the Revelation the
actual inil that he was given when we
don't know whe whether it was a Hadith
or a narration from him or whether it
was a revelation actually from Allah
from God so there's all this right and
if you look into that and you really
dive into that whether you're Jewish or
you're Christian you'll find Not only
was he a prophet of God he was one of
the most truthful one of the most
peaceful one of the most
um worshiping people and and he he had
this essence of pure monotheism last
question will conclude with this uh what
would you say to um to an Israeli Jewish
coming from that background the same way
we would also condemn I mean we talked
about this earlier we don't human life
is precious life doesn't matter from
what background race Creed color this is
straightforward so we don't have a
problem condemning you know any human
life you know this is clearly something
that is uh is evil but now somebody you
know you've seen some of these videos
mocking have you seen any of these uh
mocking some of the people who don't
have water basic uh Essentials for life
and mocking some of these de what would
what would you say to to someone who
maybe has taken uh a certain people who
are your neighbors right there they're
your neighbors and now you're taking
them as animals as um dehumanizing you
know how would you get for them to look
at the human element to look at The
Human Side to you know touch their
hearts you know coming from a background
now and you really know what Islam is
you know what being a Muslim is all
about how how would you approach if you
have a one-on-one conversation with
someone who's of that mindset the
Zionist mindset Jewish mindset and you
know what it's just the camps they went
through like you it's something coming
up right but you have a lot of people
who were also coming up but they like
you they looked and saw there's more to
this and they went investigated and
they're talking a different tone we can
maybe play a video real quick that
people can see it's people from all
different um Jewish Israeli backgrounds
who are speaking up on behalf of the
injustices are happening and they're
siding with the the Palestinians here
what would you say well I would say if
you know why don't you side with or why
don't you identify the side of your
Israeli brothers who who see the
Injustice why why aren't you siding with
them and seeing that killing innocent
civilians women and children when
children make up a third or more of the
deaths that we see the killings in Gaza
how is that justified and you can't say
oh they're going to become terrorists
one day no they're not Mo the vast
majority of people in Gaza by every news
source or every media who is actually in
there who's recording they're not there
they're not training to that's not what
they want and all they want is to end
the oppression that's happening end the
suffering that's happening that doesn't
justify an attack on Israeli civilians
it doesn't because if they were truly
innocent civilians women and children
who are dying that's against our
religion and we don't side with that but
that doesn't mean that Collective
punishment is is allowed and under what
under what case would you say Collective
punishment is did they ask for it no
they didn't ask for it why would they
ask for it they're only trying to fight
for their lives they're barely hanging
on as it is I mean all you have to do is
stop listening to the same one untone
media stop listening to the people who
you grew up with saying the same message
over and over and over again it's the
same as following religion you're just
following Zionism as a religion instead
of following Judaism as a religion yeah
thank you very much thank you very
much I cannot leave without giving you a
gift if you're not yet Muslim and you
tune in in to see what these Muslims are
talking about and you like a free copy
of the Quran go ahead and visit the Deen
show.com we'll take care of the postage
and everything and get it delivered to
you and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us at 1 800
662 4752 we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you assalam alaykum
I'm sure all of you know Eddie from the
dean show and I'm sure that you've all
heard about the dean center now you
don't want to miss on this opportunity
the brother has been around for a long
time when I became Muslim that was a
show that I used to watch it was one of
the shows that I actually was
interviewed on and since then I've kept
in touch with Eddie and we've cooperated
and participated in many things together
alhamdulillah by the blessings of Allah
now you guys have to do your part this
is for the umah there's so many people
in this world who need The Message of
Islam but the question is now what you
going to do what are you going to do
with your money with what you have what
are you going to do to help the umah to
help someone who's been around for 20
years doing dawa you've enjoyed the
shows you've enjoyed the interviews
you've enjoyed now it's your turn
support the dean
[Music]
Center